[Música]
Rusia se despidió del subcomandante de
su flota del mar Negro en la anexionada
crimea cientos de dolientes se reunieron
para presentar sus respetos al Capitán
Andrés en un funeral militar en
sebastopol murió combatiendo en la
ciudad portuaria de Mario pool en el
sureste de Ucrania es uno de los varios
oficiales de alto Rango que han
fallecido en la guerra
por lo que sea andrey nunca fue un
trabajador de oficina siempre estaba en
primera línea con los militares siempre
estaba con los oficiales y por eso
cumplió con su deber hasta el final su
deber como oficial como maestro y como
patriota hospital
Rusia ha sufrido grandes pérdidas desde
el comienzo de su invasión de Ucrania
hace un mes un periódico ruso afirmó que
unos 9.861 miembros del ejército ruso
habían muerto Aunque rápidamente eliminó
esa cifra alegando que había sido
pirateada la otan estima que el número
de Muertos rusos podría ascender a unos
15.000 las tropas soviéticas perdieron
un número similar en Afganistán a lo
largo de toda una década
Mientras tanto el kremlin no ha
actualizado sus bajas pero a principios
de marzo afirmó haber perdido algo menos
de 500 combatientes
creo que los máximos dirigentes rusos
quieren demostrar al mundo entero el
poderío y La potencia de las fuerzas
armadas rusas a las que les han dado un
golpe y una humillación importantes y en
realidad Ucrania demostró que el
ejército ruso no es tan invencible como
muchos han pensado
como el ejército ha avanzado con
lentitud las tropas rusas han recurrido
cada vez más al bombardeo indiscriminado
de zonas civiles pero Moscú insiste en
que la guerra se desarrolla según lo
previsto